you're looking live at a ship building
plant in wisconsin
president trump said to deliver remarks
there at any moment
we'll monitor it for you and see if
there's any breaking news
but in the meantime u.s marshals and
unarmed national guard troops
on standby to help protect monuments in
washington d.c
president trump vowing to crack down
after protesters attempted to topple
an andrew jackson statue near the white
house earlier this week
the president also threatening ten years
in prison for protesters tearing down
statues in an executive order he's set
to sign
and a black lives matter leader getting
a lot of attention
for saying this when pressed about some
of the violence
taking place this country is built
upon violence what was the american
revolution
uh what's our are our our diplomacy
across the globe
so for any american to accuse us of
being violent
it's extremely hypocritical if this
country doesn't give us what we want
then we will burn down this system and
replace it all right and i could be
speaking
figuratively i could be speaking
literally it's a matter of
interpretation
and in a town hall set to air tonight on
hannity
president trump going after
democratic-run cities take a look if
they don't do something with seattle
we're going to do that we're going to go
in there because what's happening
they're taking over american cities
by the way in all cases it's democrats
the democrat run
in all cases and joe biden would have
that be the whole country
it's so crazy what's happening here's a
guy doesn't talk
nobody hears him whenever he does talk
he can't put two sentences together i
don't want to be
nice or unnice okay but i mean
the man can't speak
dana uh you know mob violence is wrong
obviously but
local police should be able to handle it
and so far they're not asking for help
so
why is president trump talking about
national guard
and u.s marshals is this political
posturing
well i think that we have definitely
seen local police departments unable or
unwilling
to help protect some of these statues
from being vandalized torn down
for example the statue up in wisconsin
that was pulled down
and beheaded and then thrown in the
river was actually
of an abolitionist who had given his
life for the cause
so nobody did anything in that instance
and in that
same thing it wasn't just a statue that
got hurt it was the
very progressive progressive liberal
state senator
who got beat up so if the local police
are doing something you know let's let's
see it and i think that
if i were to put myself back in
washington dc i lived right next to
this park where the lincoln emancipation
uh statue is
and it was a gathering place where you
would have school children
coming by all the time learning more
about it getting a sense of it
and i think that the national guard
protecting
us in this moment is probably the best
thing
that we need if local law enforcement is
not going to be willing to do it
themselves
i don't think that the president is
wrong to put this on democratic cities
and some
in some cases i do wish that these
local leaders would accept the help
because we have a real problem here
and and the president we're also in an
election year
he's very good at attacking his
opponents and putting them in a position
where they have to align with whatever
the problem is
so for example the president as you just
saw in that clip is saying
i'm against the mobs therefore joe biden
is for the mobs
and so he's trying to put biden in that
position that he's going to have to
defend
the mob and i go back to this point if
joe biden has an opportunity here
to stand up and to push back on this and
say
there is a way to do changes
to statues lawfully with with a due
process you could vote i mean that's
quite an american thing we could vote on
these things
but they don't want to do this because
they're just in this fever of the mob
so i hope that tonight is calmer than um
advertised we'll see
uh greg just picking up on what dana was
saying about
you know joe biden has a way of turning
uh
his opponents uh into villains he's
tried with joe biden but joe biden's not
hillary clinton
obviously and now as his poll numbers
continue to fall it looks like he's
playing a lot of identity politics
going after people uh as the the
anti-racist protesters as
looters and anarchists and going after
people there's a question in here
or a statement is there a question or is
this a statement no no i'm asking you so
this is a statement
or a question is this going to work get
this question
that wasn't a question
trump's numbers are falling and he's
playing identity politics
i again dispute your premise i don't
believe he's playing identity politics
in fact he doesn't have to i sense that
you are playing identity politics
but we won't go there look biden and the
democrats
they cannot be critical of anything
about law and order
if they've already abdicated their role
in preserving it
they're not even trying to come out with
a statement about this stuff
so when they talk about police reform
there's it's pointless
because they can't even step up and
protect their own cities you know this
is a very depressing time but i'd like
to quote the philosopher
cody rigsby and say you know even though
things are bad
don't let the day snatch your wig
because
the bright side is when you look at
these statue pullers
they're a bunch most of them are pasty
out of shape
white losers this is not a revolution
it's a tantrum that's why i like robert
johnson from b-e-t
when he said that blacks are actually
laughing at these people
and taking statues is really kind of the
lily whitest thing you can do
oh i'm so good to you people look i'm
taking down these statues
in the name of black lives it is it is
actually a condescending
insulting act a symbolic gesture not a
practical one
you're not helping with jobs or
opportunity you're just destroying
things
huh so jesse uh just picking up on what
greg was saying bob johnson
founder of bet though he back something
like reparations what do you think
bob johnson backs reparations
right is that true i mean i i i didn't
hear that i heard him
saying that white people tearing down
statues is a joke and that black people
laugh at that
um but listen if he's for reparations
that's fine
i'm not for reparations he he has a lot
of money i'm sure he donates a lot of
that money to the black community and
good for him
that's one way to solve this problem you
know every question you've asked juan
has been kind of
just false i mean to say that trump's
playing politics while he's telling
people to knock off the looting and the
arson
or it's identity politics to say hey
guys
stop shooting innocent people i mean
like what are you talking about these
are these are democrats
who are destroying democrat cities
trump's offering to give him a hand
and you're attacking president trump i
don't think barack obama
would even allow this stuff you think
barack obama would let this stuff happen
no
he'd probably try to clean it up too but
trump tries to clean it up and he's the
bad guy
where's joe biden you know he's running
for president he wants to be the leader
of this country that's destroying itself
you'd think he'd have an opinion on the
hottest issue of the day
no one even knows what joe biden thinks
of the statues coming down
or the looting or the arson i mean i
don't know what it is
i just actually have been inundated with
texts from my
liberal family all day and it's driving
me crazy you have to give up your white
privilege
how do we renounce your white privilege
jesse you are not a black american you
don't know what it's like
you can only speak for white people you
can't speak for black people okay
i went on the black lives matter website
because i wanted to find out a little
bit more about what they wanted
you know what black lives matter wants
this is their actual there's a list of
six things
an end to the war on black people sounds
good to me
i mean if there's a war on black people
i renounce that reparations
i'm against that says the rest of the
country invest divest
i think that's about fossil fuels now it
gets a little weird
economic justice you look in some of
that
all socialism community control
that doesn't make any sense and then
political power everybody wants
political power
so if you dig deeper it's basically just
reparations and socialism
okay so dagon uh in new york city
uh the mayor there bill de blasio wants
to troll the president he wants to paint
black lives matter right in front of
trump tower
are you laughing do you think this is
funny i know that
shootings in new york city have doubled
in the first three weeks of june from a
year ago
and there is complete lawlessness in the
street
so he can do these little stunts but at
the end of the day he's not protecting
the people of new york city and he's not
standing up
for police officers and that's what you
see in these
liberal blue cities states
and even from the likes of joe biden
either they endorse lawlessness or they
tolerate it and and what ends up
happening
is writers are allowed to rule
and vandals are allowed to destroy
whatever they want
so it's not just about the statues
coming down in the middle of the night
it's about that which begets well then
there's looting
and there and there's more theft and
then there's assault
and then there's rape and then there's
murder and that is the spiral
that president trump is actually trying
to stand up
against because there's a very clear
link
between liberal law enforcement
lackluster law enforcement and and a
stretch
to violent crime and just really quickly
it is these bastions of blueness
in city-states and even in say
corporations
the most progressive corporations do the
worst
for black americans if you look at the
breakdown of the number of people
of black americans who work at a
facebook let me just throw this out
there
less than four percent of the employees
at facebook are black
and less than one at one and a half
percent are in technology jobs
that's the opportunity that mr johnson
is talking about and they're not getting
it from progressives and liberals
or the